مره اخرى الى الجانب السوري معنا هذه
المره من مدينه اعزاز بريفي حلب ينضم
الينا طبيب الطوارئ بمستشفى معبر باب
السلام وامين سر نقابه اطباء حلب الدكتور
عمر فروح دكتور عمر مع مرور الايام وطبيعه
الامكانيات فيما يتعلق بالجانب الطبي
والعلاج ما المتوفر لديكم وماذا تحتاجونه
في ظل بدايه دخول مساعده بشكل مختلف في
هذه الايام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته حياكم
الله حياكم الله وجزاكم الله خيرا كل
الشكر لقناه الجزيره على هذه المبادره
الطيبه
ونحن الان نصل الى اليوم العاشر من
الكارثه الانساني الكبير التي حلت بالشمال
السوري وجنوب تركيا
تضاءل الامل كثيرا في انقاذ اشخاص احياء
من تحت الانقاض هذه الكارثه الكبيره التي
حلت بشمال السوري بعد سنين طويله من الحرب
والدمار والقصف والتدمير التي عانى منها
الشعب السوري في شمال سوريا
تاتي هذه الكارثه الانسانيه الطبيه في وقت
يعاني فيه الشمال السوري من نقص
بالامكانيات الماديه والطبيه
اللوازم التي يحتاجها الشعب السوري في
حاله تعرض لكارثه انسانيه او طبيه هناك
شحب سحب التجهيزات الطبيه شحفه الاولويات
ماذا تحتاجون دكتور عمر كاولويات في
الايام الماضيه كانت بعضا معنا بعض
الشهادات كانت تقول مثلا انه فقط طوابير
من اجل اجراء مثل عمليه الاشعه حتى يباشر
الجراحه التدخل
الجراحي البعض كان يموت وهو يقف في
الطوابير من اجل اجراء هذا المسح الاشعاعي
وبالتالي ماذا تحتاجون كاولويه من معدات
طبيه
طبعا اخي الكريم منذ الساعات الاولى
بادرت الفرق الطبيه والمشافي الموجوده
بالشمال السوري لاستقبال جميع الحالات
الوارده اليها نحن مثلا في قسم الاسعاف في
مشفى الشهيد محمد وسيم معاذ استقبلنا عدد
هائل من الحالات عدد كبير من الحالات اللي
وردت من تحت الانقاض من شمال السوري وتم
اجراء الاسعافات الجراحيه او العمل
الجراحي لازم بالنسبه لهذه الحالات ولكن
هناك شحم بالتجهيزات طبيه شحن ببعض المواد
الطبيه او اللوازم العمليات
لذلك كانت كميه الحالات الوارده كبيره
والامكانيه الضعيفه ولم يدخل الينا شيء في
هذه الفتره عبر الحدود من المنظمات
الدوليه او منظمه الصحه العالميه او
المنظمات دوله لم يدخل الينا شيء اطلاقا
في الايام الاولى للزلزال منذ اليوم الاول
وحتى اليوم التاسع لم يدخل اي شيء يتعلق
اي اي مواد طبيه او اي اد خاصه بهذه
الكارثه الكبيره التي تعرض لها شمال
السوري في اليوم التاسع فقط دخلت بعض
المواد الطبيه او الادويه من منظمه الصحه
العالميه او w وهي مساعدات مبرمجه مجدوله
سابقا ضمن البرنامج الدوري وليست خاصه
بهذه الكارثه هذا يعني ان العالم اجمع غير
مكترث بهذه
الكارثه الانسانيه التي حلت بالشمال
السوري للاسف
الامم المتحده او او منظمه الصحه العالم